Wiki How to Train Your Dragon all right
step 1
live in a world with dragons glad to
hear they're starting with the
essentials step 2 almost killed a dragon
wouldn't seem to engender a lot of
loyalty to me but ok step 3 wait until
the dragon develops Stockholm Syndrome I
should know better than to trust wiki
how the movie has better advice
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
hey Hollywood we need some new
franchises in theaters all right I mean
just look at the film lineup for the
rest of 2019 a reboot of men and black
remakes of Dumbo Aladdin and Lion King
and sequels to Avengers spider-man Star
Wars Jumanji Rambo Terminator fast and
furious frozen Angry Birds Toy Story and
The Secret Life of pets
it's like horror films don't scare
Hollywood executives their actual
nightmare is creating new and creative
screenplays cue the airhorn because that
was a sick but predictable burn
one slip sequel that premiered earlier
this year was How to Train Your Dragon
now this is a franchise we've never
covered here mostly because I'd never
seen the movies up until recently but
having just caught up with the franchise
after a few really long flights I'm
finally sinking my teeth into these
tales of toothless by addressing the
biggest question that comes out of the
whole theatrical Empire not good dragons
exist know not how do massive lizards
fly it is way more obvious than that
today I am gonna answer the question of
how do you train your dragon and the
answer is not like you see in the movie
I mean I know the movie makes it seem
all magical and heartwarming but when
you look at the realities of what's
actually going on on screen the entire
premise goes up in flames
you should not train your dragon I'm not
talking about Oh dragon training would
be dangerous because they'll eat you and
they'll burn you with their hot fire no
the entire concept of training your
dragon is simply broken at a fundamental
level and you definitely shouldn't do it
the way that hiccup does in the movies
so saddle up Vikings of questionable
geographic origin sure you want that kid
running the village it is time to
theorize for anyone was like me and
missed out on this franchise here's
basically what you need to know for
today's theory pickup lives on the
island of Berk with his father - chief
Berk is prone to frequent dragon attacks
so like most people being tormented by a
species of wild animals they fight back
in one of the dragon attacks hiccup
injures an elusive Night Fury dragon
that he eventually names toothless and
befriends over the course of the film
through his interactions with toothless
hiccup learns that dragons are really
just glorified cats that can be won over
with beams of light chin scratches and
dragon nip children in Berk society have
to undergo a process known as dragon
training you get your wish dragon
training man I should have gone first
and hiccup skyrockets in popularity as
his tactics serve as a non-violent model
to follow for the rest of the village by
the end of the film everyone in the
village has their own pet dragon
completely forgetting that these are
enormous deadly wild creatures who were
literally
at their throats only a few hours before
sure they were being mind-controlled by
a giant dragon overlord but still you've
been fighting these things for
generations and now you're like oh look
at how cute they're no stupid bad idea
and this episode's gonna tell you why
now let's make one thing clear by the
end of the movie what we see aren't
trained dragons they're domesticated
dragon Stephanie seemed like a minor
point but it's actually a huge
difference you see in the real world we
use a lot of words about animals
interchangeably that aren't really the
same at all and when it comes to
training a dragon the difference between
words like train and domesticate is the
difference between getting you the
world's most awesome pet and you getting
personally barbecued to death so let's
get our definitions straight to tame an
animal is to take an individual wild
animal and make that specific animal not
afraid of you as a human to train an
animal is to get it to repeatedly follow
a command you blow a whistle your dog
sits to domesticate an animal is the
most intense of these three and requires
fundamentally altering the species over
many generations be a selective breeding
basically transforming it to behave the
way that humans wants so today we're
gonna address the possibility of all
three but specifically focus on training
since you know that's the title of the
movie now hiccup for all his supposed
dragon knowledge is not the example of
proper training that the people of Berk
should be following what he does is
dangerous destructive and worst of all
inhumane now that may sound extreme
until you take a second look at the
events of this film without all the
sappy feel-good music what happens to
kick off this entire movie hiccup
injures toothless wrecking his tail flap
an injury that completely grounds
toothless I mean toothed toothless
dragon without so we are starting the
relationship with a critical injury and
then it proceeds to get even worse
hiccup moves on to reconstruct a new
tail piece for toothless and while it's
all real nice and good that he works so
gosh darn hard on it it was repairing an
injury that was his own fault and as
soon as that tail pieces on guess what
toothless does does he turn around and
thank you does he tearfully tell him
that he'll miss their companionship no
he flies away he tries to escape the
human predator like a wild animal should
and would do in that moment but even
then hiccup
can't leave well enough alone because he
hangs on through the air and discovers
super conveniently that the dragon can
only fly if he master human is
controlling the prosthetic tail piece
just think about that for a second this
would be like clipping a bird's wings
and replacing its wing tips with
remote-control wing tips so we could fly
them around like a model airplane when
you really think about what's going on
here to a wild animal who's scared and
injured it would be immediately
classified as animal cruelty or at the
very least a pretty barbaric way to get
a big animal to do what you want and
hiccup sees no problem here in fact he
spends most of his time riding toothless
around congratulating himself about how
amazing is after that he goes on to
chase down the dragon to get a saddle on
it again not voluntary since to that it
has to iterate all kinds of reins and
turning systems to control the dragon
instead of rigging a system where you
know
toothless could control it himself
hiccup doesn't design or even attempt to
design something that would allow
toothless to fly independently until the
short film gift of the Night Fury and
even then he still has systems in place
that allow him to maintain control it's
like saying to your dog I love you as
long as I still have the ability to
shock collar you it's only in the third
and final film that hiccup finally
respects this animal enough that he
designs something that makes him
completely independent meanwhile every
time hiccup falls toothless crashes
headfirst into the ground at full speed
or directly into cliff faces even when
his control system works and hiccup is
managing to navigate think about what's
happening here sure it looks epic and
they're working like a team but in
reality this dragon is a helpless
passenger in his own body he is a slave
and no matter how many times it happens
he only has one choice but to keep going
cuz again a dragon that can't fly is a
dead dragon the long story short here is
that whether he had good intentions or
no he kept used
to train this dragon he stripped away
its independence and toothless was
required to submit to it so what should
hiccup have done to train his dragon
well it comes as no great surprise to
anyone that it would at the very least
be a lot harder to train a gigantic
lizard than it looks like here but is
there any world where this is possible
using anything even remotely like the
real methods of animal training could
you train your dragon maybe there's a
way that this story could have turned
out better
maybe we call it film theories guide to
how to actually train your dragon it's
catchy maybe it just needs an acronym ft
ght a tyd look at what hiccup should
have done if you were actually training
a dragon or any kind of reptile that
even remotely resembles a dragon because
I want to give him a fighting chance
here referring to reputable zoo and
reptile resource guides the ft ght a tid
immediately encounters a few issues
other than its terrible name because in
most places you look that respond to the
question of how do I train my reptile
they answer with you don't
to quote safer pets an online resource
about training and caring for exotic
animals quote first it's important for
you to realize that your pet lizard will
never be like a dog or even a cat you
will never be able to have the same
level of interactions and trick training
as with a pet dog if this is what you're
after then you might be better to
consider a different sort of pet maybe
not with that attitude
safer pets know but seriously why are
they so negative towards this whole
thing is it just that we haven't spent
the last few millennia domesticating our
local crocodiles and that's why they're
not willing only fetch oh no it turns
out that the problem with training your
dragon or any other reptiles starts with
the brain have you ever heard anyone
refer to their lizard brain he usually
use the phrase when you're referring to
some impulse decision or reaction that
you just can't control like your
involuntary reaction to a jump-scare in
a horror movie or how I seem to eat the
entire box of springtime Oreos before I
even realize it every single spring
through the basic Oreos but I still I'm
like oh they're yellow frosted greats
these are all primal reactions it tastes
good so eat it it's scary so run away
these lizard brain actions are
controlled by the three most primal
areas of our brain the brain stem the
cerebellum and the basal ganglia
which aptly enough are the same areas of
the brain we share with lizards
including reptiles reptile brains are
just much smaller than mammal brains
relative to body size because they only
need to have these three areas for
reference a saltwater crocodile and a
horse have almost identical weight
ranges from 800 to 2200 pounds
a crocodile brain weighs in at about 8.4
to 15 grams while a horse's brain weighs
in at 532 655 grams so why are their
brains so much bigger well humans and
other mammals like dogs and cats have
other areas of the brain layered on top
of those primal areas called the limbic
system which allow us to have more
complex emotions like how dogs
experience excitement to see their
owners or depression when they're
abandoned the limbic system also enables
us to develop trust and behavioural
pattern recognition that allows us to
train and be trained reptiles literally
don't have the parts of the brain
necessary to develop relationships with
humans their brains are missing the
emotional cognition to be trained to do
the types of tricks that you see in How
to Train Your Dragon no come on I hear
you saying there's videos on YouTube of
people training lizards like Komodo
dragons duh even have dragon in their
name but that kind of lizard training
looks very different than training a cat
in a dog the most advanced dragon
trainers in the world who work with big
lizards like Komodo dragons can only
train them to do what's known as target
practice lifting a rifle onto their
shoulder and shooting at a target
downrange I just did that to see if you
were paying attention no you cannot
train your lizard to shoot a gun target
practice here means basically classical
conditioning for your dinner instead of
throwing some mice or other animals into
the reptiles habitat trainers take a
target basically a ball or a plate on a
stick into the enclosure and train the
reptile to touch the target in order to
get its food that's it like that is the
level of training that you can do for
your dragon vn biologically speaking it
is impossible to do much more than that
and the reason trainers typically even
bother doing this is to
move reptiles to different areas of
their enclosure to receive things like
medical care or give them exercise not
become helpful pets or even show off for
the zoo visitors reptiles in captivity
are known for being lazy and lethargic
because they don't have to defend their
territory anymore their lizard brain is
no longer needed for survival so the
only way to get them appropriate
activity is to get them to work for
their food even the crocodile hunter
himself Steve Irwin describes using
himself as bait in crocodile enclosures
so the Crocs would regain their sense of
territorialism and fend him off to get
their blood pumping this is a very
rudimentary form of training and it
certainly isn't for fun it's because to
keep the reptiles healthy they have to
use their instincts because that's the
only thinking that they're capable of
doing anything you train a reptile to do
isn't them being loyal to you it's just
them using an instinct all that said for
all you reptilian apologists out there
it's important to understand the
difference between intelligence and
emotional complexity reptiles are
extremely smart
so just because they're not emotionally
capable doesn't mean they're not capable
capable they have memories that span
almost their whole lifetime and big
reptiles like alligators can navigate 30
to 40 miles of waterways easily from
when they're born which can be said for
basically none of us who are working on
or watching this video because human
babies are virtually useless reptiles
are also pretty much the kings of
Darwinism where a lot of female reptiles
will only give the green light so to
speak to the biggest strongest male in
their area meaning that the only genes
that get passed down are from the very
best of their species but we as humans
who don't really care about that and
instead just won a cuddly iguana can't
mistake all of that for love or loyalty
or trust or any of the emotions that we
hope to get out of a real pet reptiles
still aren't domesticated after all
these millennia but that means that
whether you're adopting a dragon from
the wild or you're picking up chameleons
at the pet store literally the pet that
I've wanted all throughout elementary
school you are adopting the equivalent
of a wild animal so how do you train
your dragon one you set realistic
expectations that you won't ever
a true relationship with them too you
beat him around an enclosure to give him
lots of exercise and three you
appreciate that they're instinctual
e-waste smarter than us but don't know
how to brag about it
relationships just don't figure into
that equation which is a real bummer
because it would be totally amazing to
ride your alligator in Florida or watch
your basilisk lizard skip across your
bathtub but at the end of the day you
cannot train your dragon' which means
that the FT ght 80 yd is finished and
that means back to the drawing board for
me the dragon circus kangaroo best
friend a kangaroo can be your best
friend yes anyway before I go remember
that is just a theory aa film theory and
cuts